<👏>
Meme Review.
Youtube's favorite show, everybody.
meme review.
<👏> Clap it up <👏>, everybody <👏>.
It's time for another episode.
What is he going to say about memes this week?
I don't know  it's so exciting.
Yes, it is!
Thank you.
Unfortunately, I have terrible news.<chuckles>
<queue sad piano music>
I'm gonna give you guys a warning.
To click away this video.
Right now.
I know you're not gonna though.
Slimey little scumbaggy.
Like you've got anything better to do?
I know why you clicked on this.
That's why I called you slimey.
I know that you know,
That I already know,
That you know.
Okay?
You're just here for some Bowsette
Aren't you?
Ew!
Nasty!
I like that though.
I like that. (☭ ͜ʖ ☭)
Bowsette.
#Bowsette.
It's taken over the world.
It's taken over the planet.
It's taken over the universe.
When our planet will cease to exist , one thing that will keep on living
is Bowsette.
Aliens will find scatters (Fragments?)
of our artifacts and it will be written upon it:
Bowsette
And that's all we really need to transpire..
Across the universe.
Hail the Queen Bowsette.
What is Bowsette?
Yes ofcourse, it's in the name.
It's the female version of Bowser.
we have officially done it, bois
The #Bowsette was trending worldwide in
Japan!
Bowsette has been on... has been going on for a while.
But this is the tweet
that started it all.
by HaniWAH
It's a wedding.
Peach says: NO
Mario is super SAD
Bowser is super SAD
But then they look
at each other..
and
OH
MY
GAAAAWD
Bowser became Bowsette
and they
SMASHED
I added
the last part.
Sorry.
I love I ...This Is It
This is all it takes to
break the internet.
People posted this hashtag, I mean...
You can't go online
without seeing Bowsette somewhere
You just can't.
Did Bowser lose weight?
Is it hot in here?
Or is it just me?
Cause Bowsette is looking very attractive
Sorry, Marzia.
I just feel like I , I wanna be honest
<Mr. Miyamoto> : So how are the
fans enjoying the upcoming game in the switch games?
<Reggie> : Everyone seems to be talking about NSMBU and the super crown
<Mr. Miyamoto> :
Ah yes, now the people can play as Peach
Hooray
Uhm..
<Reggie> : It seems they like its for a different reason..
Just look at Bowsette
Look what they did.
Look what they did, Mr. Miyamoto.
A close-up of my eyes?
Peach is screaming internally,
of all the  Bowsette fan fiction.
Besides, is there anyone that has a pencil and a paper has
decided,
YES ( ͡⚆ل͜ ͡⚆)
Yes, I am going to draw Bowsette.
What else am I going to do with my life?
I don't get it, like..
I feel like this whole thing is a sexy Phil clickbait title
People are freaking out over Bowser, and here's why..
I still don't get it...I still don't get it.
Hey look it's the Bongocatbowsette.
<INAUDIBLE>
At some point we have to just be
responsible
And say: <???? > <EXPLOSION>
Perhaps we were all just ignorant.
Perhaps we were all just blind.
Bowsette has been in front of us since the very beginning.
anyway thing could be bow saying oh my
God..... I see it now.
Bowsette is incredibly
attractive!
How could I have been so blind?
Okay we definitely can't show this
<LINK IN DESCRIPTION>
Okay...
<👏>
Obviously this meme is still blowing up
there's not really a much of important for me to rate it
But simply makes me
physically ill and attractive at the same time
<👏>
I'm gonna have to give it a 5
It's a perfect balance meme
whoop
<👏> NEXT
<👏> MEME
Intermission is that
what it's called.
Just wanna point out.
Okay, Bongo cat still doing strong still
going strong everybody.
Bongo cat is doing great
Thank you for asking.
So while you waste your time with stupid Bowsette
Just know there are positive sides out
there there are positive movements
This is not really much of a meme it's more
of a meme war that I feel I have to acknowledge
We got the m14 gang versus
the Olympia gang in black ops zombies
whatever it's called, I'm not a nerd I
don't play video games
I'm not some loser..
especially that plays
Call of Duty
<baby pewds> How's it going bros, my name is poodiepie <baby pewds>
Made by m14 gang
Imagine unironically using the m14
Made by Olympia gang
Ouch!
That one's gotta really hurt.
We all know that the m14 is the superior
anyone that picks a shotgun in any video
game is just a moron that can't aim properly
<Kids with an opinion>
STUPID
The m14 takes skill
it takes accuracy and you know what
It doesn't matter when the dogs come yes
there will be bears technically superior
for that moment triggering speed with
your finger which of course any 114 gang
all the way transit bus driver B like
this poster I mean you think I'm gonna
let you bum on my bus with that Olympia
in your hands this is epic guys this
post was made by m14 gang and I approve
this message
now of course I will pass on the
question to you guys are you part of the
m14 gang or the Olympia game just
passing the question on to you guys let
me know in the comments down below I
really want to hear what you think and
not just get more comments on my video
passing it on to you guys you have to be
probably one of the dumbest people on
the planet to pick in the Olympia but
what do you think passing the question
on to you guys let me know down below
Apparently the goal here
my from my positive memory of a
childhood that is English apparently
stop ruining old things Nintendo just
stop next
meme everybody commit you're scared a
minute to appreciate me review and all
it's done for everyone has it made your
life better
probably not but smash like if you're
enjoying this episode actually smash
like regardless last meme of the week
everybody
Netflix adaptation mean we have the
manga very nice we have the anime oh
it's pretty good
Netflix adaptation wow you make me sick
get you out of here he's fat and ugly
the manga whoa the anime wow that's
pretty accurate they did a great job
Netflix adaptation manga hey look is
Marzia. Anime wow that looks really
accurate Netflix adaptation I don't know
why Netflix is so keen
just murdering or every anime ever I
will never forgive you Netflix for what
you did to Yagami like why are we still
here
just suffered
NEVER FORGIVE NEVER FORGET NEVER FORGIVE NEVER FORGET
Screw you NETFLIX
EHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHhhhhh
<EXPLOSION>
Manga.. oh goddamnit.
Manga
Anime
Netflix
You know what?
I'm gonna go on..
I'm gonna go on a limb here
and say that ..
The anime is the best
You know it won't live long, but it's one of those memes that will just..
~WEIRD HAND SHAKE WITH GHOST?~
It will live here, it will live here. I'm gonna give it a 4.9
<👏>
Meme review, everybody.
Youtube's show.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Leave a like if you enjoyed. subscribe if
you aren't... (?)
So we can stop T-series?
Eh, see you guys tomorrow with another video.
BROFIST
THERE
<A$$ OUTRO>
<LINKS IN DESCRIPTION>
<LIKE & SUBSCRIBE>